but first let's talk to the foreign
secretary liz trust who joined me in a
studio good morning foreign secretary
um
where is the military balance this
morning
well what we're seeing is we're seeing
that the ukrainian forces
are continuing to resist
russian advances
we haven't seen
overnight significant changes
in what is happening on the ground but
we are seeing i think unexpected by the
russians very very strong and brave
ukrainian resistance and it's our role
as key supporters of ukraine to continue
to supply them with defensive weapons
continue to supply them with economic
support to help them resist this
egregious invasion to what extent do you
think that uh mr putin
has failed to object his first well
three-day objectives
we said before this invasion took place
that vladimir putin would be making a
massive strategic mistake
first of all because the ukrainians
would fight and we're seeing them fight
we're seeing the incredibly brave
leadership of president zielenski
but also because they would be hit
by severe western sanctions and last
night the g7 agreed that we would cut
access for russia to the swift banking
system that we would target the russian
central bank that would be putting more
sanctions on oligarchs and companies and
you can see the reaction in the
international markets you can see the
damage already to the russian economy
but i fear trevor that this will be a
long haul what i'm saying though is that
the united kingdom absolutely stands by
ukraine through this very long and
difficult conflict by the way when you
talked about long-haul it's report this
morning you said this could be 10 years
this could be
a number of years because what we do
know
is russia have strong forces but we know
that the ukrainians are brave that
they're determined to stand up for their
sovereignty and territorial integrity
and they're determined to fight
and the sanctions that we are putting in
place
and they are very very tough sanctions
cutting the russian economy at its knees
cutting access to the western system you
know we've banned aeroflot from flying
into the united kingdom uh we're
targeting key oligarchs we've got a hit
list of oligarchs but these will take
time
to have an effect and debilitate the
russian economy we need to wean europe
off
russia and oil and gas this will take
time so this is not going to be a fear
over quickly but we need to be prepared
for a very long haul i want to come to
the sanctions question in a moment but
um sticking with a military issue
what actual military support are we
offering to ukraine
so we've trained up 20 000 ukrainian
soldiers uh we've put support into the
ukrainian navy we've supplied anti-tank
weapons
which are being used by the ukrainians
and we continue to supply
defensive weaponry for the ukrainians to
use we've also led the defense secretary
led a donor conference on friday with 25
other countries they have pledged also
to support and last night we saw that
germany has changed its position germany
is now going to be supplying defensive
weapons into ukraine so we're seeing a
huge uptick and britain really has led
in this we were the first country
in europe to supply defensive weapons to
ukraine we're now seeing others supply
defensive weapons as well and this is
vitally important to help the ukrainians
resist
the russian invasion and the russian
advance and what we're also seeing is
just the huge motivation
of the ukrainian forces you know they
are fighting for their country but
they're also fighting for freedom and
democracy and it's vitally important
that putin's ambitions stop in ukraine
he's he's stated publicly that you know
he wants to regain control of vast ways
of eastern europe whether it's poland
moldova the baltics we must make sure
that we are doing all we can to back the
ukrainian resistance
there's clearly as you say great
resistance here
but
one of the things that i think is now
being contemplated is
if the russians feel that they are being
frustrated their response might not be
to step back it might be to deploy
greater fire power
how serious do you think this could
become
i i fear you are absolutely right trevor
we've already seen
the response from the russian government
we've seen the actions taken despite all
of the warnings about the severe cost of
this conflict in terms of humanitarian
costs in terms of cost for the russian
state i mean this could well be
the beginning of the end for putin and i
fear that he is determined to use the
most unsavory means uh in this war but
he should be aware that the
international criminal court is already
looking at what is happening in ukraine
and
there will be serious consequences for
him personally
and for the russian government how far
do you think he can go i mean he has
uh
chemical biological weapons he has
nuclear weapons how
bloody could this actually become i fear
this conflict could be
very very bloody and we've already seen
uh
civilians targeted uh by by the russian
by the russian government i urge the
russians not to escalate this conflict
but we do need to be prepared for
russia to
seek to use
even worse weapons i think it would be
hugely devastating russia is already
isolated internationally the u.n
security council not a single country
voted with russia
everybody is dissociating themselves
from russia they have been cut off from
the international community financially
diplomatically
politically and that would simply make
it even worse we saw in syria the use of
chemical weapons
banned weapons
could that be a factor here and
you know one doesn't run over dramatizes
but let's be frank ukraine was the site
of many what used to be called
battlefield nuclear weapons
are we talking at in the worst in worse
circumstances that kind of carnage
we need to avoid this at all costs this
is why it is so important the work we
are doing to degrade
the russian military complex we're
stopping
the export of technologies to russia we
are stopping the ability of those
military companies to raise money in the
international markets we're cutting off
uh the swift system from russia
precisely say that they cannot fund this
war machine anymore
we have said that we're standing
shoulder to shoulder we are going to do
everything for ukrainians well of course
one of the consequences of this action
even before any of the kind of things
we've just been talking about happens
will be a flow of refugees 150 000
apparently have left un talked about 5
million some of those people will want
to come
here
what are we going to do
to admit those people from ukraine who
maybe have families here at the moment
the visa regime
seems
extremely bureaucratic and restrictive
have you any thought about how it's
going to be made easier for people to
flee
well the prime minister has already been
very clear that we are a country that
welcomes
refugees that we will do all we can to
support the ukrainians we're already
putting in a lot of humanitarian
assistance at the border of course the
main thing we can do is support the
ukrainians to fight for their country so
that they can have a long-term future in
ukraine that's extremely important
trevor but telling people whose families
are here who are ukrainian
who want to bring their families out
that you have to apply for a seasonal
work visa does not sound that welcoming
we are looking at what more we can do
trevor the prime minister was very clear
last night that we will will be
welcoming refugees from ukraine we're
already expediting our visa processes or
passport processes we've got a 24 7
operation running at the foreign office
helping people with emergency travel
documents but i can tell you trevor we
are looking at what more we can do
we're saying we'll be saying more about
this very shortly well i hope you you
you might want to say something about
that today because right today people in
ukraine are saying we have to travel to
live to get a visa in ukraine if we want
a british visa we have to get out of
ukraine to poland or romania or moldova
that is not easy that is not welcoming
why not simply say that people who can
get from ukraine to here who have
relatives who have a place to go will
have at least a temporary visa and then
you can do the investigations and all of
that why not be clear about it today
because in
in kiev what they're hearing is the
british aren't that keen on you coming
well first of all i can completely say
that is not true
the united kingdom does welcome refugees
and we want to do all we can to support
ukraine economically we're supporting
the humanitarian effort i had a call
last night with the united nations about
how we support
making sure the humanitarian
response is completely in place how we
protect humanitarian corridors out of
ukraine so we are doing
all that work
i know it's difficult and i completely
appreciate the difficult of
communications in ukraine there is an
online system that people can use
to apply for visas but as i say we are
looking urgently trevor we're looking
urgently at what more we can do to
support people in ukraine but i want to
send a very strong message the united
kingdom
welcomes refugees are people on the
ground in ukraine are not
i are hearing from people in ukraine
that that is not the message they're
hearing what they're hearing is it's
difficult to come to britain and what
after they've come complained that we're
a bit slow and getting the weapons and
all the rest of it
it's not a great look for us is it
well can i just pull you up on the point
about the defensive weapons we were the
first we were the first
we were the first european country
to send
defensive weapons to ukraine
we have had a long-term programme of
training up the ukrainian armed forces
we're now seeing other european
countries also send defensive weapons
which is very welcome we were the first
country to call for swift to be cut out
from the russians we have put in the
toughest package of sanctions of any
european country so we will always lead
and we will also lead trevor on the
humanitarian and the refugee effort and
i can guarantee that to you today all
right let's come on to your ground which
is a diplomatic territory uh there is uh
reports there are reports that the
belarusians have tried to open some
conversation
with
the ukrainians today
what do we know of that and what do you
think this means
well what we know is throughout the
diplomatic discussions we've been having
the russians have lied when i was in
moscow i was assured by sergey lavrov
there would be no invasion of ukraine
that was not true president putin said
there wouldn't be no invasion of ukraine
that is not true so what we know
is that the russians
weren't and aren't serious about
diplomacy this is why our efforts should
be focused on supporting the ukrainians
fighting ukraine to defend their country
and cutting off the russian economy from
the international system and degrading
the russian economy now if the russians
are serious
about negotiations they need to remove
their troops from ukraine
they cannot negotiate with a gun to the
head of the ukrainians they need to
remove their troops which is what they
call for they need to de-escalate this
conflict and i see absolutely no signs
of that we're continuing to see a
russian offensive in ukraine so frankly
i don't trust
these so-called efforts of negotiation
so no talks until there's a with
complete withdrawal
absolutely uh
we talked to you've talked about the
sanctions uh already um
in yuval you and i have discussed this
uh those sanctions before you've
obviously had some success with getting
uh other countries to
do something about the swift system
the other sanctions uh
that we might be looking at are for
example in relation to uh energy um
in 2014 david cameron along with other
european leaders vowed to reduce our
dependence on russian energy supplies
in 2014 we in the uk actually bought
zero cubic meters from russia
in
the last year we bought 6.4 billion
cubic meters they have to be a rocket
scientist to know that actually
we applied sanctions but in fact we
bought more
gas from russia why is it going to be
any different this time
so we currently i think three percent of
our energy supplies are a russian gas
which is a lot lower uh than many many
european countries i mean some are up to
85
of all their gas comes from russia so
what we need to do
is we need to agree
with our g7 counterparts because we're
not going to be able to do this alone we
need to agree to reduce that percentage
over time
that that's what's important so i would
support the idea of having ceilings on
how much
oil and gas is imported from russia so
over time we cut uh the dependency right
across europe
and that's what we're working with our
g7 partners but you're absolutely right
trevor
that the west did not follow through
yeah and that is why
that is why that's why we're in the
situation we're in now
is we didn't do enough
to deter putin in 2008 and 2014 and that
is why our sanctions will be much
tougher
that is why
the germans in particular have cancelled
nordstrom 2 they're now supplying
defensive weapons we've seen a huge
change which i very much welcome because
we need to take a different approach
we simply cannot afford to be importing
russia and oil and gas we cannot afford
to have
such a strong russian presence in our
financial system that is why we're
prepared to take tough actions that will
ultimately be difficult for our economy
in the short term but will help protect
freedom and democracy in the long term
yes but i i if i may say so i think that
that all sounds
right and good but the problem is that
it went in the wrong direction last time
you have to work with other people and i
suppose we're not going to get let it go
in the wrong direction this time i am
absolutely determined trevor the prime
minister is absolutely determined not to
let it happen again
brian o'toole who was the treasury
official charged with
essentially leading on the
devising sanctions regime after 2014
uh said to me in the interview we're
going to run later in this program that
actually you have to understand there
are limits to what sanctions can do
they could they knew that they couldn't
get putin out of crimea in 2014 with
sanctions what they hoped to do and what
he thought they did was to delay further
aggressions what is our real objectives
with sanctions here he's not going to
bit back out of ukraine because of
sanctions is he
the real objective is to degrade the
russian economy
because what we know is that putin's war
machine is funded by revenues from oil
and gas so what we have to do is reduce
dependency
on oil and gas we have to cut the
ability
of russia to raise money on the
international financial markets we're
cutting the technology that they can use
in their military complex they've got
very advanced weapons we're going to
stop them accessing western technology
so over a period of time it's harder and
harder for putin to fund his army harder
and harder for him to create that new
technology and harder harder and harder
for him to wage war but i completely
agree with your analysis that this will
take time all right this is why i'm
saying this is a lot going to be a
long-running conflict the ukrainians are
and will resist it's very very hard for
russia to gain permanent control over
ukraine when the public of ukraine do
not want that and that is what this is
why we warn putin that this would be a
long-running quagmire but the role of
sanctions is degrading the russian
economy over time all right let's talk
about a couple of things that we can do
um
when again we spoke you said that there
would be nowhere to hide for putin's
associates the oligarchs now roman
abramovich has relinquished control of
chelsea football club but he still owns
it
and that means that if you come after
his assets for an example if you were to
come after his assets
chelsea football club would be beyond
your reach in truth
unless you change the way that all
companies operate in london the
oligarchs and their british lawyers will
still be able to protect their assets
won't they
well this week we'll be introducing the
economic crime bill which will create a
lot more transparency
around the structures of these companies
and make it much clearer uh what is
going on i've compiled a hit list of
oligarchs
people who is abramovic on it i'm not
going to say who is on the list but what
i can tell you is there are over 100
billionaires in russia
we have compiled a hit list of oligarchs
we're working through and putting the
cases together and every few weeks we
will sanction new oligarchs there will
be a rolling program of sanctions we
will go through the hit list we're
targeting oligarchs private jets we'll
be targeting their properties uh we'll
be targeting uh other possessions that
they have and there will be nowhere to
hide
all right look um
lastly everyone knows newton's law to
every action there's a reaction we have
we'll do the sanctions and so on
it's estimated that uh energy bills
might now climb to three thousand we can
expect inflation above eight percent
ukraine produces grain price of bread
will rise so there will be a cost to all
of this
for us
i wonder um
for us to make a difference
our people are going to have to
face some suffering
some consequences
are you going to level with the british
people that in order to force change in
moscow
people in manchester and maidstern
bertha tidfield anywhere else begins
with m are going to make sacrifices in
this country is for what neville
chamberlain once described as a quarrel
in a faraway country between people of
which we know
nothing
are you going to be clear with britain
that if we're going to
fight this long battle they are going to
have to sacrifice
well first of all the sacrifices that we
are going to have to undertake in
britain are nothing like the sacrifices
that people in ukraine are suffering now
they are having to arm themselves they
are having to fight on the streets
due to a completely unprovoked invasion
by the russians
and my thoughts are with the people of
ukraine and the difficult struggle that
they they they have ahead of them
but we're not just fighting for the
people of ukraine
and the sovereignty and
self-determination of ukraine
this
long-running
conflict is about freedom and democracy
in europe
because if we don't stop putin in
ukraine
we are going to see others under threat
the baltics
poland moldova
and it could end up in a conflict with
nato we do not want to go there that is
why it's so important
that we make the sacrifices now and yes
there will be an economic cost here in
britain there will be a cost in terms of
access to oil and gas markets we don't
import much here but
there are
there are a lot of um
imports into
a continental europe from russian gas so
inevitably there will be impacts but we
have to
and i i firmly believe the british
public
understand the price we would pay if we
don't stand up to peter now
the price we would pay is much greater
in the long term and frankly
over the past 15 years we haven't done
enough to stand up to putin we're now
facing the reality of what that means
and that is why we are taking a much
tougher stand now
liz trust thank you very much thank you